le document que nous allons vous montrer
maintenant outre son caractère
exceptionnel
interroge de conscience il a été tourné
en irak par nos confrères philippe
rochot et alain st au beau milieu de la
guerre fratricide à laquelle se livrent
les hommes et les enfants de com est uni
contre les troupes de saddam hussein
c'est précisément des enfants dont il
s'agit dans ce reportage
pour faire la preuve s'il y en avait
besoin que ces gosses non content
d'aller se faire tuer sur le front sont
aussi des armes dans la guerre de
propagande à laquelle se livrent les
deux pays sous les portraits du
président saddam hussein six enfants
combattants iraniens capturés sur le
front ont été présentées ou plutôt
exhibé devant la presse
car les conditions dans lesquelles s'est
déroulée cette rencontre était
humiliante pour ses enfants de 12 à 14
ans encerclé par les flashs des
photographes et les objectifs des
caméras
ils avaient été capturés sur le front à
l'est de basra quelques jours auparavant
ils portaient encore leurs tenues de
condat qu'on leur avait lavé et il
passait ainsi de la guerre à
l'atmosphère feutrée d'une salle de
conférence ont-ils eu de la chance
d'avoir la vie sauve
ils n'en sont pas convaincus l'ayatollah
khomeini refuse de récupérer ses fils de
l'iran car ils auraient dû dit il mourir
au combat
il est révoltant qu'un pays envoie ses
enfants se faire tuer mais il est aussi
choquant de voir son adversaire l'irak
les utiliser pour servir sa cause et la
presse internationale
accepter de telles conditions nous ne
pourrons avoir le contact avec ses
enfants que par l'intermédiaire de cet
homme qui filtre les questions mais les
réponses ont été préparés à l'avance
notamment quand on demande aux enfants
comment ils ont été engagés dans cette
guerre c'est à cause d'une grande
propagande dans le pays va répondre ce
garçon de 14 ans on m'a obligé à
combattre
on nous a dit allez vous battre pour
l'islam mais parfois c'est la bavure
ils répondent par exemple qu'ils ont
quitté l'école pour aider leur père
alors que les autorités irakiennes
veulent leur faire dire que les écoles
ont été fermées afin d'envoyer les
enfants sur le front l'interprète
officielle va même démentir les propos
de ce garçon alors que peut-on croire
dans les réponses de ses enfants
la gêne est évidente chez tous les
journalistes qui participent à cette
mascarade et une certaine honte apparaît
dans les comportements
la réalité c'est que ces enfants qu'on
nous présente comme les victimes de la
propagande de khomeiny reste convaincu
du bienfait de leur cause
une journaliste iranienne de
l'opposition autorisés à séjourner à
bagdad a pu s'entretenir avec eux
écoutez d'abord donc journalistes y
étaient scandalisés par cette conférence
de presse je crois que je peux pas la
seule et seconde doit en tant qu'iranien
zhu je voulais avoir un contact direct
avec avec ses enfants donc j'ai demandé
aux responsables irakiens
autant avec eux je n'ai pas eu de
problème ils me l'ont ils me l'ont
accordé autant avec des enfants j'ai un
problème parce qu'ils ont refusé au
début de me parler ils m'ont demandé de
respecter la tenue islamique donc j'ai
porté le tchador avant de pouvoir leur
parler
alors on nous a présenté ses enfants
comme les victimes de la propagande mais
d'après vous est ce que le désir de ses
enfants d'aller à la guerre est sincère
oui je pense que le désir est sincère
certainement il ya une grande part de
propagande qui joue donc on peut dire
qu'ils ont été victimes
mais eux mêmes ne se sentent pas
victimes eux voulaient venir vraiment
sur le front venez venir défendre la
patrie et défendre les siens alors la
vérité est difficile à trouver mais
entre l'iran qui envoie ses enfants se
faire tuer l'irak qui les utilisent pour
les besoins de sa propagande et une
presse avide de sensations
ces enfants de la guerre du golfe sont
victimes de plus d'une atteinte aux
droits de l'homme